je vais faire passer un message
ce n'est plus très tôt
on sera dépisté tôt plus on aura le
maximum de chances de guérir et je
pouvais hammam a manqué ce matin faut
faire des efforts dans la nuit pour
réussir je peux être à côté d'elle il
faire oublier ses douleurs et aller de
l'avant même si elle avait rien et tout
ira mieux mais j'avais aussi dit vu que
maman souffre beaucoup et que les gens
ils savaient puisse pas trop tôt donc
vaut mieux faire les défis pour dire
mieux passer ce message
non j'ai pas perdu tout ce qu on a
expliqué que avoir des appréhensions ça
sert à rien ça
safouane juste dans la vie faut pas
avoir peur de quoi avoir peur de rien
aller de l'avant mais c'est surtout que
les gens m'écoutent de sun dépister tôt
ci soit isu qui sauf qu'ils ont quelque
chose d le dépister tôt et betfair
bethesda génétique parce que j'ai
découvert cave où sont nés garçons tous
veulent avoir le cancer du sein